citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for The Conjuring I know literally
nothing about this movie me neither not
zip zero zilch want to be scared excited
for it I hear that this is a Catholic
thing so this little Jew girl is going
to do a really good job with this are
you a horror movie Girl movie girly kind
of more recently got into it that's Tara
Erickson you can follow her at Tara
Erickson I'm Roxy strike follow me at
roxystryer and don't forget when you are
here leave a like leave a comment
subscribe
about
first time in person with the Bell thing
yep it's really good I had to get her I
had to do it like basically what needs
to happen is I had to cut her off and
just like throw her in it you know quiz
what's the next line of the song
ring the bell The Bell the Bell it's
just Bell it's like they do the ring the
bell and then they say Bell a lot and I
just figured skip it if you want more
belle things and all the other things
then make sure that you become a patron
we're gonna be ringing your bell all day
long
it came out weird it came out weird
that's where we do our entire Reaction
watch along so check us out over on
patreon please if you want to be a super
sexy reject should we conjure up some
Conjuring
okay let's do it
[Music]
we just heard that this is based on a
true story which doesn't make it
creepier at all still trying to figure
out if that's a fact or not yeah I think
Greg might have been messing with us I
don't know when you hear it you're gonna
think we're insane please from the start
Camilla got in touch with a medium we
learned from her that a seven-year-old
girl named Annabelle Higgins had died in
this apartment she wanted to live with
us by inhabiting the doll we said yes
what in the actual it plays like a
comedy so far
when we came home
sitting in the hallway but we had left
her in the spare room
well she was an artist
a really good one
no way is this based on a true story
this feels like a recreated one of those
like TV movies that's like recreated
yeah because someone told a story one
time yeah really weirdly shot at the
beginning interesting
what a wig
we made it through our first jump scare
congratulations neither of us jumped I
only moved it's like
what's an inhuman spirit it's something
that's never walked the Earth in human
form so the doll was never possessed no
it was used as a conduit it wanted to
get inside of you that's what she said
what are you guys well we've been called
demonologists it's one name for us but
we prefer to be known simply as Ed and
Lorraine Warren there for me good is the
palest
of all of the actresses
based on a true story bro there is they
kept it locked away until now shut up
foreign
do you believe in any of this kind of
stuff I mean maybe
ghosts like slightly but I don't know
why they don't come to visit me have you
invited them
I get my own room
do I get to pick my own room or do I
have no choice in that either well it's
me
[Laughter]
oh
let's go
oh my God is that hey come oh no because
remember they were like the
seven-year-old had to inhabit the thing
oh the dog knows the bad juju of the
house yeah yeah dogs always know they
know earthquakes they know tornadoes
they know even seizures
hey Mom can
I come in okay it's gonna be dark soon
it's kind of a cool runner from the
front of the house to the back of the
house I agree always a great tactic in
horror movies because you just don't
know what's gonna poke its head out okay
what is this like Marco Polo second clap
oh it must be like oh you said is it
Marco Polo yeah it must be that but like
inside a house I guess I've never played
this hide and seek clap game before
all right we'll break now
aggressive Sis hey Nancy can you go give
me the matches please what's going on
Nancy broke something shut up I feel
like a flashlight what do you see down
there it's an old piano and a whole
bunch of garbage
doll doll
come on up
but she's gonna take the matches the
doll couldn't get her to come inside I
can't leave her out there she's all
right I got her on a chain
hey be quiet place your bet does the dog
live no yes ah no it's gonna be sad and
they're gonna be mad and what's wrong
said he died you left her out there I
hate it now that you mention it I hate
this movie it's actually very good
do you think maybe we could have bought
a house that has a toilet that actually
works and there was this really funky
smell in my bedroom last night like
something died is it the dog
no
okay I'll be up in a minute I'm gonna
see if I can get this furnace working
yeah that'd be nice it's freezing it's
like wouldn't you put a little more
research into the house that you're
buying yeah like you just discovered
that room and all of a sudden the
furnace is down there like what were you
gonna do before there's a plan like
ouch I didn't do that
[Music]
wrong
oh don't the Bell is UN wrong
dang it Roxy called it such a bummer oh
man this this is why nope
what happened
no thank you
kill every human in every movie I'm all
right with it he was gonna make it to
the end of the movies he didn't make it
five minutes she really didn't
everything you see in here is either
haunted cursed or has been used in some
kind of ritualistic practice I
interviewed Patrick Wilson once he was
the coolest guy
let's say is the uh Annabelle doll here
right this way
it was a good way of describing it yeah
because then you let all the souls out
evil Souls Georgiana can you take Judy
upstairs oh sure you can't go into this
room no matter what remember I think you
may write a positive article ooh a
non-skeptic
I hate that size coming out stop blaming
yourself did she say stop blaming
yourself yes okay so yeah all right this
is very smartly done you're doing all
those little drops the bruises the
matches the furnace not working don't
blame yourself yeah oh well written
script I guess Joey King
that's her name oh came to me I could be
wrong but I think that's what it is
grabbing my foot Shut up I didn't do
anything stop
fart Nancy's probably like my sister
sucks why is she waking me up to tell me
I fart and I'm grabbing her feet it's
weird it's really weird I wish I was an
only child
it's not an invitation honey you don't
have to go you could just be like well
going off to bed now
and 100 what I would do yeah that was
interesting anyway good night
[Music]
sleepwalking again and farting yeah I
used to sleep walk as a kid me too it
ended when I was like 18 and then I just
haven't done it since I would go
downstairs and put my underwear in the
cereal boxes
oh my God
by the way that was my morning routine
what she was doing just banging your
head up against the wall
maybe we should gift that out another
day 2023. she ended up in Andrea's room
to even kind of freaked her out that's
not good
girl you're my friend right yeah let's
play oh great she's talking to the doll
right
who are you talking to
that's a seven-year-old that can see the
maybe a friend oh really yeah do you
want to see him oh with this Dad Birdman
Music Stops the mirror standing behind
you but you have to twist the key
s up creepiest part of the movie so far
no
okay you get to ask me for three classes
okay one three I'm gonna go high now
four seven
eight looking at the dolls to see if
they move they didn't
oh no oh great she's dead oh okay he's
still alive no I don't think they're
gonna kill the littlest kid this early
on man then we'd have to sit in that for
a while
no no no no oh God she almost also
there's rugs this is not a safe game
there's two stories to this house there
you're not understanding that
there's three with the basement
spirit is a real big fan of just opening
doors in the beginning I while we're
here hiding
give me the third clap
oh that's creepy as all get up oh no
why don't I can't hear you breathing
those were like male hands those are
like big hands
off I win I wonder if the mom's actually
sick
thank you
stop it Nancy Nancy stops
it felt like it was just possessing her
for a second right or something the way
she sat up right like like I thought it
was like pulling her up
oh great why do we even have to look
um
let's see
bro you see her yeah she's dead asleep
she's right there Nancy
what there's someone
's over there
I don't think whispering's gonna help
baby I would just run at the door
smell again it's standing right behind
you
not the silence bro
[Applause]
talk to me that it wants my family
she's a good little actress yeah Joey
King bro I'm pretty sure she's like a
gen Z staple yeah I feel like I know her
like older but in this movie I'm like
dang girl
oh my God dang girl I think she's
probably also sick
it's moving past door opening to just
like breaking pictures next thing you
know chandelier is going to fall in
mom's head for prediction why did the
other girls not just wake up from that
sound yeah how did they not like scream
who is that okay now the other girls you
just heard your mom scream who is that
somebody wake up yeah right like what's
going on mom she's nightmaring I don't
know
think she's gonna get locked in there
shite well you called that one bruises
I need the girls to wake up like yeah
this is this is too it's it's been very
loud this whole time
[Music]
oh my goodness
damn another sick shot
here we go
this is using the Jaws tactic we are
like halfway through this movie and no
images
I want to play hide in class
so every time Dad was like what oh yeah
because the mom was always present when
he was like what's that sound I was like
was it just Mom getting beat up the
entire time
oh good old night routine too that you
hear
sleep with me tonight right
I am not gonna not watch that closet for
the rest of this time
[Music]
I don't know is she gonna be like I'm
right uh
um
[Music]
what that was not a doll that oh was
that the mom all messed up and that's
why she was like giant like no that's
the mom oh no that's the mom okay oh my
God whether it's a Ghost spirit or an
entity and this is where the victim and
it's usually the one who's the most
psychologically vulnerable breaks the
victim down leads them to the third and
final stage possession they're just
giving these lectures all over New
England I guess Northeast there's
something horrible happening in my house
could you come and take a look it's
getting kind of late we really need to
be hit show The bruises oh watch she's
gonna show him and they won't be there
oh they're gonna be there
you have a daughter won't you do
anything you could to protect her please
can you come and take a look of course
I guess the bruises had nothing to do
with that scene at all that's not not oh
my God she's like see how it bruises oh
God where did they go well rancid smells
could indicate some type of demonic
activity well that's to keep those doors
from banging at night does he come in
threes yeah stops IT Dawn uh-huh Satan I
was here when we moved in there's also a
lot of stuff in the cellar show me the
seller
picking up anything in here hun
everything everything seems an awful
happened to your head those bruises
from something that happened here that's
some
iron deficiency thing I have yeah but um
it all started when you moved in the
house Mom and Dad tell me that you have
a friend his name
do you mind if I try to see Rory this
girl's like a little Drew Barrymore yeah
why would you want to do this for a
living great question she didn't even
know if it is for a living what's the
payment plan hey
thank you
what is it
uh
oh my god I've been seeing the dark
entity that haunts your house and your
land
[Applause]
it was latched to your back
oh dang and it doesn't matter where you
go
this dark vanity has latched itself to
your family and it's feeding off you it
would just be impossible sometimes when
you get haunted it's like stepping on
gum you take it with you
my presence here can make things worse
why and whatever you're dealing with
here isn't gonna like us so we're gonna
have our guy do some homework on the
property push her down the stairs yeah
look at all these bruises man it got
your present
honey one for you and one for me oh I'll
put a picture of you and Daddy and mine
I miss you and Daddy
miss you right because they're like
she's like on the road I mean they're on
the road I guess all the time it's built
in 1863 by a man named Judson Sherman
who was married to a woman named Beth
Sheba they had a baby and when the baby
was seven days old Judson caught her
sacrificing it in front of the fireplace
holy junk Tree by the dock climbed up
proclaimed her love to say and cursed
anyone who tried to take her land and
hung herself
tree called it death was pronounced at
307 in the morning she had a boy named
Rory who mysteriously disappeared in the
woods then she killed herself in the
cellar
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so it's like a gang of ghosts
how much do you think it is really based
on a true story like how much of this do
you feel like they're pulling from or at
least what people might believe to be
true stuff I feel like people probably
believe like 75 of this is true
what's this uh do oh and there's an
instant drop in temperature a thermostat
triggers the camera to take a picture
it's cool
stay at the beach huh you should have
seen Roger and the girls
I've never seen them so happy
pretty far out isn't it yeah yes groovy
far out and groovy words I miss words I
still use
oh is he gonna baptize them what's in
the bottle
holy water
that's uh it's water but it's holy rocks
Brad get the camera
I wouldn't go touch her yeah yeah why
why can't we just like wait on it for a
second all right it's 9 18 we're headed
down into the cellar where the doors
just opened on its own
I have Lorraine and officer Brad
Hamilton with me let's keep the solar
light off
yeah that sounds right reasonable
rational
why
the sign that you want to commute
the ball
this is a microphone that he is holding
close to things yeah
bounce your ball lady it doesn't always
work when you want it to yeah maybe the
camera picks something up
I'm gonna take a nap the late nights are
they're getting to me oh the house
hasn't felt like this in a long time I
think the kids feel a lot safer with you
around why don't we just leave them with
you yeah like I haven't felt like this
for a long time what they have such a
beautiful family don't they You've Got
To Have Some
I'll start with the Chevy
did they lose their kid
and we're just seeing like ghost images
I feel like yeah it was either that
flashbacks and like yeah because like
maybe it wasn't her the thing that I
thought like the exorcism having to hurt
like they probably lost a kid during
that too maybe I don't understand we've
already acknowledged that the demons on
their backs and then you're bringing
them into your home it's just not yeah
no but remember he was with the little
daughter at the beginning
that was cool ah that was awesome
looking
she's not sick
[Music]
are you okay I'm fine you sick I woke up
just feeling a little nauseous that's
all I thought I saw I hear Roger and the
girls okay because that's how the ghost
gets in you right they like throw up in
their soul into your mouth and now she's
like haunted she is the the weakest link
that the step two or whatever Obsession
or oh the uh possession really means a
lot to us to have you here just want to
say thank you though for coming out man
to man over a car engine whatever
Lorraine sees it helps people but it
also takes a toll on her a couple months
ago we were working on a case she saw
something
it took a real big piece
I locked herself in
didn't talk didn't eat didn't come out
for eight days
what did she see I don't know and I
won't ask I got the Goosebumps I feel
like maybe you should ask yeah it feels
like a husband I won't ask I'm not gonna
ask my wife how she's doing
absolutely not men
I don't know and I won't ask okay
lots of rocking chair
which brings the first stage
oh
already let it inside probably obviously
right Ed
it
it was a woman dressed as a mate
Ed oh my God are the flashes is gonna
keep going off now that would be cool if
it was just like picture picture final
new pictures of Cindy
trigger it
what do you mean she didn't trigger
somebody's with her yeah on her back
there's someone else in there with her
that's my kid the door is already
knocked down come on yeah
she hides on top of that thing yeah once
those are locked
shut off the light
I think you're right about being on top
of the cabinet let's just look up
foreign
[Music]
hides when he's afraid
hon could I have April's music box
please
no
is that a new Oh I thought it was like a
noose could be I do not want to see
what's on the other end of this
oh
yeah
oh it is okay yeah yeah makes sense
oh my gosh Vera Farmiga fell so far that
was multiple stories that was a cool
shot I wonder how they shot that it
really looked like she was like falling
[Music]
hooray
the rain
check the seller yeah I mean she went
down
so you see him and then what what's your
problem
oh that's the mom over the boy
she sacrificed him but then she
yeah killed her herself slow turn no
thank you
absolutely not
uh
[Music]
she made me do it like Annabelle
Shook on that one gracious
[Applause]
she possessed them under a child
she gives us Carolyn every night that's
what the bruise marks are she's feeding
off of her the necklace is how her kid's
always with her remember yeah
[Music]
uh
Nancy oh God
whoa
[Music]
catcher
bomber about her hair yeah gonna have a
weird haircut for a bit it's like a gum
stuck in your hair the footage developed
and get it over to Father Gordon I
imagine we get a pretty fast response
gotta go get your necklace bib
oh
oh okay Judy
oh God
I had a vision of Judy in the water
I know it was some kind of warning get
the necklace yeah man I don't know why I
feel like that matters but I do it does
gave it to you so you she could always
be with you the kids aren't baptized
and the family they're not members of
the church oh come on the approval would
have to come directly from the Vatican
that's so intense I thought the church
says love everyone yeah exactly just be
like yeah let's help him out
oh you saw the hand on the first one no
I did not I only saw the face in the
second
here
Daddy
that's very cool set design like she
like matches the wall and red stairs
like what The Shining yeah red rum
I'm gonna go in that room she's not
supposed to
what if the doll is gone like out of its
box
oh snap she is
foreign
[Music]
Mom Dad Nana someone
that dark dang
not hiding that room
oh
[Music]
yeah do you want to get back honey get
back
oh my goodness
Annabelle's traipsing around town man
you think she's gonna be in the case or
no yes good question she probably right
she's like well gotta get back
okay
still in the case
they saw the chair fly yeah
scared she's gonna hurt her kids yeah I
would be too
oh wait she joke
and the little one
oh okay Bad News Bears yeah she's like
full-on oh no it's Roger there's
something going on with Carol Andrew was
here and she said that Carolyn took off
with Christine and April the girl said
she smells like rotten meat oh Roger get
back to the house now I'll meet you
there you think I'm gonna let you walk
into this
not lose you
he won't let's finish this together
somebody's not making out of this
and I'm not just talking about the dog
anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
I am freezing is it because this is
freezing yes
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh
are you aware to take her to the priest
wait where's April
April oh now you can get your necklace
[Applause]
whoa if we take her out the witch will
kill her
whoa
[Music]
oh my God this is Goosebumps city right
here I have to find April okay I promise
where is April
[Music]
oh
yeah let's get something to tie her up
[Music]
the news yeah all right that's what I
was gonna say
you need to leave
I have to do it the exorcism
what I thought you said we need a priest
you're not a priest well you got a
better idea yeah
God brought us together for a reason
yeah this is it I'm gonna get the book
what book The Bible the exorcism book is
that a book no I don't know there
probably is one right I don't know
they're like number one stop start
speaking the Bible number two throw holy
water number three the end Santa
wow
[Applause]
oh no
[Music]
did it just like make all the ghosts
into crows I don't know you know the
birds have been killing themselves
against the window the whole movie yeah
[Applause]
oh
Google
how do you hook up with someone after
that
you don't know you're just like we're
divorced that's it
[Music]
oh my God I command you to reveal
yourself tour
keep going maybe
oh okay
based on a true story only a fantasma or
omnis Legion dominated
[Applause]
Do not drop her
down put her down don't say it like that
yeah but speak more Latin
[Laughter]
[Music]
why is he Standing On Top of the wobbly
thing
him she's already gone April
I thought
oh boy yeah are you sure that nobody was
even looking for her yeah
are they gonna have to kill the mom
here
[Music]
yeah
right there
[Applause]
yeah they're gonna have to kill her
before she kills her kid right that's
how it's gotta go down
absolutely
wow I condemn you back to hell
don't let this thing do this you gotta
fight it I know you're stronger than
serious you gotta fight it he's so
monotone right
that's it get her back remember what you
showed me
you said they meant the world to you
try to get the kid out though like don't
just stand there yeah
[Music]
ah
Sun heals all
[Music]
he's so scared of her yeah that would
suck
[Music]
oh is this gonna be some callback like
the ghost hasn't left where she's like
oh she's giving her the necklace uh I
think so
okay good
but I do think we didn't kill the thing
it's gonna just find a new home yeah
like this music is making us think
happily ever after but it's like for who
dog
the Vatican approved the exorcism
bureaucracy
I just can't read when you're there
I'm a whisper out louder I said
my bad
where is he Rory
[Music]
I don't see anything in there right no
what all right look at the kids oh my
God
whoa
that's bizarre
goes
uh Peter saffron
Walter Hamada
it's almost like a DC movie
I want to go there to the haunted
artifacts Museum
are you Gathering that these are all
newspaper real newspapers right yeah
Patrick Wilson
looks like a dead ringer for her
Lily Taylor okay
shall we King baby you called it
it's a cool way to do credits Yeah by
like showing us who's who because the
based on the true story thing
modern day ghost hunting
good job with that music Joseph
I mean I'm trying to see an interview
with these real people you know yeah me
too talking about it me too
that was really good very good that felt
like a you know I we see a lot of horror
movies nowadays that feel like Indie Art
House or horror movies this felt like a
big massive franchise old school horror
movie yeah I agree and they didn't like
I didn't feel like the times when it
could have gotten corny felt corny it
felt real to me like I was in the I was
invested most of the time and and a lot
of like horror movies there's a lot of
times where I'm like oh come on man like
you kind of see it coming and for this I
I maybe it's just because the acting was
so great that made it really believable
and I was engaged the entire time the
acting was really great I was a little
nervous in the first minute and a half
of this movie when we start with those
and I was like this is kind of playing
like a comedy to me and I I felt so
thrown in with the girls that were
telling the story I'm kind of surprised
we didn't jump back to those girls at
all yeah they they were an interesting
window in and then we kind of just Dip
set on them which was I'm curious what
the conversations were like around that
but nothing against those actresses but
just for some reason the performances
weren't like lining up for me with what
I was hoping this movie was going to be
right and then we jumped into 1971
with all of our people with
um Vera and Patrick and Ron Livingston
and Lily and all the kids and I was like
oh okay this is going to be really
really good like right when we got there
I was like oh they totally have
confidence in this story in the script
yeah every aspect of it so there's a
Conjuring 2 right yeah and then there's
an Annabelle movie
yeah well that just came out right with
the girl that dances
no no no no you're thinking of um what's
her name Megan uh never mind I think
there's a name she looks like that doll
that's why I thought that maybe there's
yeah there isn't it I don't I'm not sure
what all the sequels are of this but it
makes sense that it's a franchise
because obviously they set up I love
that it's a full story but they did
leave room for you could go a thousand
million directions yeah for sure I mean
not evil spirit's just floating around
town Massachusetts land yeah I mean that
for sure you could think of like who
else that Spirit would go to and also we
could follow Patrick Wilson and Vera
formiga as they do this with other
people or other Spirits or different
Conjuring things yeah like in the
beginning where they were shooting where
it was like maybe as soon as they cut
back to them at the University in the
very beginning and he clicks off the TV
and you're like oh thank God that's why
I felt like a TV movie and you're like
oh it was his footage or whatever
um yeah that found like the found
footage kind of style yes we which I was
like oh you could keep doing that but
then keep up with the style of like yeah
we're still gonna shoot it like Doper
than that yeah like the Warner shots and
the
totally it was like Blair Witch for a
second and then it was like wait a
second this is supposed to be a very
high budget big franchise movie I feel
yeah like you said that one shot there's
a lot of really cool like when she was
falling how did they I would have to
like go back and look at it in slow-mo
to be like oh did they just replicate
her falling through one and then just
like make it seem like it kept going
like because he cut away from it and cut
back to it but that shot was so cool to
me and also all the rest of it but it
did still feel very big budget even
though we are just really in one
location the entire time which is
normally a great way to like save on
budget it's like a horror you're like
one location awesome
um but they really knew how to play with
the environment maybe it's because we
took like a couple of breaks away from
it
um by going to the other house by going
to the school like just being outside a
little bit yeah totally like that gave
us a a little bit of like my I guess a
breath of fresh air and back into real
life to be like well what's actually
going to happen once we arrive back at
the house like what can we learn more
being outside of it and I guess we
learned the most once their daughter was
in that room and Annabelle was not there
yeah and they were like oh so cheap free
roams what is the connection to this
whole story and specifically Annabelle I
guess that was like part of the piece
that is missing a little bit for me is
that we know that this house is for lack
of better words haunted we know that
there have been multiple suicides and
deaths in this Han in this house
and we know the story from the girls
that Annabelle was a real person asked
to be like put in the doll right so it
didn't seem connected to the story that
we were watching right it because the
story we were watching was like they got
that house and then that woman was like
I sacrificed myself to Satan and all of
this land and then kills the daughter
first or whatever then kills the son and
then kills herself so maybe they were
just setting up with Annabelle the doll
that that's what they do and oh that
they take over but then member Vera
farmiga's character I keep forgetting
whatever but Vera Yuga she said it I
don't know she was like they don't take
over things they take over in the very
beginning she was like they don't take
over things they wanted to get to you
meaning like it took over the doll but
they it want it wanted just to get to
you to a human that's what she said to
the girls which I found very intriguing
and then when you see the doll
no longer there and they're like oh is
it because it got to the daughter
through the doll which daughter her
daughter or the other people's daughter
her daughter right so that's with the
doll but what did the what did Annabelle
have to do with the nothing or family I
that's what I'm I'm like I think it's
maybe it's totally separate and it was
just trying to give us an Insight that
the
Spirit isn't trying to go through isn't
like inhabiting a a doll or a picture
frame it's using those things to get to
the humans so I guess when we see things
move that we're like oh yeah it's trying
to get to the to the girls but still I'm
with you on that I don't see the big
connection I'm sure you guys at home are
like this is what it is yeah please let
us know and that's totally fine it
didn't deter it didn't distract me it
didn't depend on a movie for me but I
did kept I kept thinking when we open a
closet or on top of it or whatever we're
gonna see the the doll yeah and then the
doll was never there instead it was the
music box and then at the end when
Patrick Wilson puts hit the music box in
his thing I was like oh that was the
doll has nothing to do with this family
or that thing this was their thing the
whole music artifact right I wonder if
they're just doing that because they had
already read both the scripts and
they're like we need to give some juice
on how these two people started their
whole paranormal activity it started all
with Annabelle and that was their very
first I don't know if you said that in
the college talk he might have been like
and that was our first case and maybe
that's why they showed it and then maybe
the writers were like let's just show a
little more juice because the next one's
gonna be about Annabelle I don't know
yeah because Annabelle I feel like I so
I don't know much about this going into
this I didn't know much about it I knew
like I said James Juan Patrick Wilson
because I uh when I was interviewing him
for Aquaman oh yeah the both of them who
were both awesome I was like researching
what they had done together and I was
like okay so this is a team up and there
was a lot of stuff in Aquaman that was
very horror-esque did you see I did so
at the beginning it's like this
Lighthouse and it's kind of got that
same audio mix that you feel like a lot
of horror movies do or like the windows
are kind of slamming against it even
though it's not a horror movie at all
yeah you kind of see his imprint on it
so I kind of wanted to see where that
came from even though I didn't end up
watching this movie so that had stuck
with me and other than that the only
other thing that I knew about Conjuring
was this doll Annabelle like I yeah I
had known Annabelle is the doll from
Conjuring so I I maybe I just did that
to myself where I kept thinking that
Annabelle was going to be the big thing
right because that's the only thing I
knew and I'm wondering why is Annabelle
so famous from this movie when she kind
of like just chilling yeah she's just
chilling but I but I thought like while
I was watching it that I'm like isn't
there a house where they're like this
Annabelle doll actually exists and you
can take a tour yes okay yeah that's a
real thing yeah and I heard about that
and then I did make the assumption that
this was going to be about that
especially when you open up on the girl
saying that but it's really just like
I guess it was just like oh
a piece of information but I'm still
like why would they give us it's not
like related I guess she's just an
overarching like this stuff exists and
people get like the spirit dements these
certain things and then the Soul stays
locked in a in an item right and like a
through line for the franchise which
probably they were already thinking
about yeah they're like well we're gonna
have to maybe the obvious is to show
Annabelle in the first one they're like
we're not gonna
I'm kind of glad that they did though to
be honest because you know we've got all
there's so many franchises with the
dolls right with yeah Chucky and um just
like I feel like it's a you just made it
clowning it up you mentioned Megan
there's a lot of dogs so this did
differentiate itself the music box
really did work for me everything about
this was true truly scary yeah a lot of
the horror movies we watch now are that
borderline it's more like oh it's kind
of creepy this was a this is scary oh
yeah I mean I I really did get
goosebumps a few times and I think what
made this movie win in a lot of moments
is like I felt emotional when the mom
was like I am so sorry and also
emotional when Vera was helping her and
reaching putting her hand down being
like you don't want this remember this
this moment which I thought was a really
nice callback because I felt her being
there and that being the thing that
helped like pull her out of it was like
obviously her children and her family uh
and they set it up in a way that like
wasn't too over forced with this thing
we didn't have to see it a lot but I
felt it so the pacing and the tone of
like the way they brought that up made
me feel something which in other movies
I'm like oh they could put that there
and try to have a call back to it and I
would feel nothing but this movie did a
really good job of balancing like what's
going on it's scary but also you feel
for these people because of what they're
going through definitely I agree with
that thinking about feeling for these
people too I feel like a lot of a lot of
this movie asks you to bring your own
thoughts to it in terms of like you
think about that Mom that we saw kill
her kid right yeah and for years
everybody's just thought that this mom
killed her kid and like that that's the
I think like if I was a spirit you don't
move on until things are cleared up
right right and this mom everybody's
thinking his mom just murdered her kid
and the mom's like I didn't do that like
I just possessed I didn't just decide to
murder my effing child you know right so
maybe that does help the spirits move on
to kind of have their families character
come in and see things that did happen
and be able to like understand and say
out loud speak into the universe this is
what happened here she did yeah you know
the the thing possessed her and that's
how it all went down
it's it's it's weird though because like
when when the mom says like look what
you made me do like we're seeing that
she is possessed but they tell the story
sadly that something happened with the
mom and the mom was just like I give
myself over to Satan and then kills her
first child as a sacrifice and then that
was still the same mom that was like
then killing the sun in the basement
right I don't know the story makes it
where I feel for her too but then I
remember that they're like oh but like
she like gave herself over to Satan her
land and that's why there all these
people are like demented right but is
that was that just the origin like lady
that they were speaking of and the lady
in the basement was a different woman
who is now possessed because she lives
on that land and that Spirit was there
taking the latter of God I'm gathering
yes now I'm with you because I was like
is that they're telling the story and
there was multiple people multiple times
yeah and there's a lot and I think
that's kind of on purpose too where they
really want this goes back I think they
mentioned the 1800s right and then they
talk about all the different families
who have lived there and they show us
photos and whatnot so so they were just
telling us about the origin woman and
then the woman that we see who's like
look what she made me do which by the
way I can't stop every time I hear it it
look what you made me do the song yeah
but she was like look what she made me
do and then she runs into the guy and
she says that look what she made me do
and all of that and then we watch her
she's definitely possessed she's yeah
like she didn't want to kill her kid a
hundred percent is what I gathered from
that it just sucks that one woman had to
ruin it for everybody and all these
people are just like going on to the
land being like we're gonna buy a house
and have a nice life and now this lady
she's like Satan come take over the land
speaking of women having to ruin it for
everybody
I'm stoked this is our they've been
asking for me and you team up and we we
did it I know
a team up together watching a horror
movie
just a bunch of it they're just gonna
make us
we're going to be the horror girl squad
where do you think that this does rank
in your you told me at the beginning
that you are newer to the horror scene
like you've been more getting on it do
you feel like is this up there for you
with the classics or is it more kind of
like a modern classic for you hmm
no I mean I would I would put it
I would put it up there only because I
feel like it it didn't hit like tropes
that I thought was like too corny it
just hit where it was like this is scary
and creepy but also I feel like it's
real and there I feel something in the
moments that I'm supposed to which makes
it like a winner for me so I'd I'd put
it like up at the top I also always say
I'm like it from 2017 top movie of that
year I love that movie so much that was
the movie that got me into horror movies
really terrified to see it but I had to
watch a trailer reaction a bunch and
when I edited the trailer reaction I was
like I can watch these jump scares
because I like just watched it a lot and
that convinced me to go see the movie
meanwhile I was like I'm not gonna see
it I'm just gonna react to this trailer
and then I went to go see it I'm like
this movie is fantastic and so after
that I have watched horror movies
because I I was just always so scared
that I would be absolutely terrified and
not be able to watch
um and like this this movie is great
because there's a lot of times in
certain horror movies uh I mean I just
watched rack with Greg rack is also a
great wreck it's like Rec like recording
and it's in Spanish and that's a
fantastic horror movie as well and the
reason I put that up also at the top I'm
like because I feel something the
characters are very very real and it
also happens to be like scary and spooky
um because there's a lot of times in
some horror movies where they don't get
the part where I'm like just let it
breathe for a second so I can feel for
the people in the movie yeah and I I
hate that when they skip over the park
because then I don't care yeah I'm with
you where I I don't come from a horror
background so I really need to be
invested in characters and premises like
it's it's not enough for me to just be
scared I need there to be something to
you know hang on to yeah I feel like
this really did a great job with that
this is going to be such an obnoxious
comment and I don't know where I came up
with this from but I kind of thought
this movie was going to be trash I I
have no idea how I thought that not even
trash isn't bad but trash isn't like
corny cheesy like yeah just one of those
um I I don't know like shitty bee like
horror movies or something maybe maybe I
don't even know why I thought that
because I guess maybe I don't hear
people talk about The Conjuring in the
conversation that they do about these
great horror movies but maybe I haven't
been talking to the right people because
to me when we were watching that I just
kept being so surprised with how awesome
this movie is in in all aspects with the
sound design with the way that it looked
with the characters with the
performances yeah the way that the first
two minutes are is kind of how I thought
the whole thing was gonna go right and
then when we switch I'm just like wow
that movie was phenomenal I really hope
that this franchise holds up and that
right we get to watch the next one
hopefully I'll dug this movie too and
want us to watch the next one because I
I want to see Conjuring 2 after this oh
yeah me too also if there is an
Annabelle which I feel like there
probably is
like we got to get to that as well for
sure maybe in like it maybe in uh years
from now we'll see some kind of a Joey
King spin-off of that oh later on that
would be that she's so good yeah like
what yeah it was nice to have kids in
here that were good yeah I'm like like
you said like the little girl Hermione
of Drew Barrymore sort of like um in E.T
Drew Barrymore is like I will I re-watch
E.T and I'm like the fact that Drew
Barrymore is that good and she's like
five I don't I don't know how kids do it
I really don't crazy and the same for
Joey King Joey King same for Joey King I
mean she's not five but she's young
still and she does a fantastic job being
emotional I believe her some might say
that Joey King is a queen
some might say that we're a queen
[Music]
if you want to see us do Conjuring 2
please make sure you write that in the
comments also let the people know how
much you like the team up we need it I I
have a uh a team up name with John where
Ron joxie you and I need to think so you
guys let us know all of that as well if
you're not already a patron please
become one don't forget again like
comment subscribe do you do an outro
bill I don't but I'll ring the bell
well as you go ring the bell
it's pretty good it was a good height
now good right and we're ending this
with the patron of the day shout out
Garth McMurray my dude
I'm obsessed with Garth because he loves
comic books and he's back from the East
Coast like me and he's just a dope dude
and he's an unbelievable artist too
actually well you draw stuff Garth do
you this is a crazy thing about Garth
Garth will take a um uh white or dry
erase board what are those things called
yeah yeah yeah whatever and draw like
something that I couldn't draw if I had
50 years to draw it with like a real pen
and Pad it's crazy but you know you're
my guy I always want to give you shout
outs when I can so thank you for being
an awesome super sexy reach
yeah man I mean sketch us up you know
send us a sketch email it to me oh email
email it email email me a sketch Garth
show me the juice she can be a bunny
because that's their yeah I can be
Spider-Man yeah
bunny bunny spiders mine's cooler thanks
guys bye
this is for the sink it's my favorite
line you stole my favorite line sorry
foreign